Steve Jobs once echoed a quote
originally attributed to Henry Ford that
said if I had asked people what they
wanted they would have said faster
horses the implication being the
consumers don't know what they want and
it's the job of entrepreneurs to
anticipate people's needs such as horses
being replaced by cars but the Internet
has changed things we're now living in a
world where consumers are clued in wise
to technology and deeply aware of what
they want in the realm of gaming
inviting player feedback can bring about
a better product or simply earn goodwill
and show transparency to a loyal player
base a currency that's worth a lot
especially for ongoing games that hope
to retain their players game development
is rarely a trouble-free endeavor and as
with the majority of sizeable online
games the division too has run into its
share of bugs and balancing issues since
launch but massive entertainments
transparency around these issues is
impressive constantly evolving online
games are often doomed to be in an
endless cycle of rebalancing bug fixing
and maintenance while there's an
advantage in the adaptability such a
model offers the constant flux and
change ability can prove to be a
double-edged sword one issue is that
players expect constant change
improvements and new features I got in
touch with massive entertainment
community developers Peter Martinson and
christophe gans left to find out how
they engage with and incorporate player
feedback they said we want our community
to know that we see the development of
the division to as an ongoing
relationship that said we and the
players don't always agree on everything
we need to constantly have a holistic
view of what goes in and what goes out
of the game but we discussed the
feedback we get on a daily basis when it
comes to what can and can't be
implemented they explained our designers
and production teams know the game
intimately
they know what's feasible and what's not
feasible and they know how certain
changes that are being requested would
or wouldn't work practically sometimes
feedback can be laser focused on a
specific aspect of the game that if
changed could have much bigger
implications that you don't directly see
at the same time many of our players
also know the game very well so nothing
is discarded Martinson and Gansler said
keeping up with the development demands
of a constantly
evolving game can be hard though very
rewarding the division to released as
new reports of intense development
crunch popped up within the industry
epic employees have described unending
and brutal crunch periods while working
on fortnight a demand of the ongoing
nature of the game the practice of
crunch which requires extraordinarily
long hours is becoming a particularly
publicized issue across the industry I
asked her massive viewed crunch culture
and they said when it comes to
developing online evolving games or
games as a service there's less ramp up
and ramp downtime than during
traditional game production we're
actively working to prevent teams
working overtime and when it does happen
we have very clear rules and
communication about the practice for
example overtime has always paid in
accordance with Swedish work regulations
work-life balance is essential if we
want to attract and retain the best
talent to continue developing games on
the same scale and quality as a division
2 having spoken to the developers I
wanted to ask the division 2 subreddit
community how they felt their
suggestions were being heard and
implemented while it is important to
note that those who replied represent
just a small sampling of the community
there were some interesting shared
sentiments over all the players who
responded said massive is communicative
and transparent citing examples like
when the community asked for skill and
weapon changes at launch and those
adjustments were implemented very
quickly several plays noted that
sometimes this responsiveness turns into
over responsiveness and that things have
changed as a result of player feedback
that don't necessarily please everybody
an example of this is the original plan
to increase the gear score which
essentially functions as the game's
level cap from 500 to 515 this didn't
end up happening after some player said
they didn't want the score increased and
massive ultimately decided it was too
early to introduce higher gear score
items given everything else that changed
in title update 3 but the community is
very divided on whether this is a good
or a bad call on the other side of the
coin a number of players myself included
were not a fan of debuffs on weapon mods
and a massive made the call to remove
them there
thousands of threads YouTube videos
forum posts and tweets out there from
incredibly clued in Division two players
reporting back with what they want to
see change in the game
many of these raise criticisms of
ongoing bugs loot drop issues and enemy
AI balancing among many many other
requests this is something massive seem
to be taking pretty seriously they
explained sometimes things go wrong and
we don't believe in hiding from our
mistakes we're human and mistakes happen
transparency is very important for us
it's part of the DNA of the project of
course we can't talk about everything
even if we'd want to that's just the
reality of the game's design and the
business this relates to the most
interesting point of praise that the
players I spoke to mentioned they said
that even if they didn't like the
implementation of a certain change they
appreciated being included in the
process there is an undercurrent of
dissatisfaction in the division to play
a base right now but I do wonder if the
reason players keep vocalizing their
criticisms is that they have an
expectation that they're being heard and
their opinions are not falling on deaf
ears in just the last week one of the
highest upvoted subreddit posts
simply read when there are issues with
the game most of the time the devs are
silent but it is nice to know that the
devs care and are talking about the
issues weekly this is in the midst of
dozens of suggestions about what could
and should be changed but the fact that
both sentiments coexist is important to
many players feeling heard and respected
and knowing that the game they throw
hundreds of hours into is developed by
people who care what they have to say
and open about their successes and
failures is more important than having
every suggestion they want implemented
it's this level of communication and
transparency that results in place
feeling a loyalty to a franchise in a
studio and that's something no amount of
money or marketing can buy
four massive with the division to those
conversations take place through the
regular state of the game live streams
on Twitch through Reddit and Twitter and
YouTube the game's official Thorens a
newly established official discord
server and occasionally in-house
workshops where community members are
invited to speak on the game's
development the emphasis on hearing and
incorporating player feedback isn't just
lip service for massive and the division
- and they aren't the only ones
listening when I was discussing this
video with colleagues and online
communities many of them had an
immediate idea of at least one other
company they thought was doing a great
job at engaging with their community and
incorporating player feedback for
instance a reddit user reached out to
tell me that since launch rare has done
a really good job of keeping the sea of
Thieves community looped in with every
new change
similarly respawn has gone at a
reputation for their great to develop a
player relationship throughout the
development of apex legends the latter
is a particularly interesting example
given respawn has publicly stated
they're choosing to space out content
updates so they can avoid subjecting
employees to crunch the respect and
Trust players give to the studios who
make the games they love seems to go
both ways as Martinson and consolate
told me we know that feedback always
comes from the love of the game so even
if it's something negative players just
want the game to be better we appreciate
that we're at a curious point in the
games industry right now gamers are very
clued in and discerning they aren't
buying marketing and pretty cg trailers
at face value like they once did
game developers from high-profile
studios are speaking up about poor work
conditions and treatment more than ever
the smoke and mirrors that shaded the
magic of game development is fading from
all sides and it's forcing game studios
to change adapt and most importantly
communicate image and honesty are
becoming more and more important for a
studio and ignoring legions of fans when
they're making it quite clear what they
do and do not want can have some fallout
76 sized consequences that is quite
apart from the rippling effects of a
fanbase who feel betrayed all the
consequences of a tarnished reputation
as a result of reports from a workforce
revealing alleged exploitation trust and
communication breakdowns between develop
and players are becoming a disappointing
trend of late so actions that illustrate
respect to both employees and gaming
audiences of being more celebrated than
ever everyone likes to feel heard and
respected and it'll be no surprise to me
if the game studios who are really
listening to their player base and
embodying these values are the ones who
maintain their audiences and in-house
talent